قبل أن أرى القاهرة، أشعر بذلك أولاً، مرحبًا،
كيف حالك،
تجربة القاهرة فوضوية بشكل لا يمكن
إنكاره،
وأتساءل ما الذي يحدث هناك ولكن التزم به،
التزم بخطتي، يا له من
ساحر تمامًا في نفس الوقت،
انظر إلى هذا،
هناك دفء حقيقي في هذا  ضع
الناس يرحبون بك،
مرحبًا مدينة الألف مئذنة
لمزيد من التاريخ، المزيد من الأساطير أكثر جاذبية من
أي مكان آخر، نحن
نتحدث الآن فقط شاهد، لقد
جربت هذا، إنه أصعب بكثير
مما يبدو عليه
التباهي، الآن
أصبح شائعًا  أنين وأنين من
المطالب التي تقدمها القاهرة للمقيمين
والزوار على حد سواء كم هي تافهة وتافهة أو
من القلعة أستطيع أن أقدر القاهرة
وكل صخبها
هناك مدن هناك عواصم
ثم هناك القاهرة فقط أنظر إليها
بكل روعتها أو  ملهمة
بالطاقة الخام وتتركني أتساءل من أين
أبدأ،
تراه في الضباب
الأهرامات أول لمحة عن أي
زيارة إلى القاهرة تفرح القلب
وتضحك
لاحقًا،
بدلًا من ذلك، استمتع بنوع مختلف
من
السوق المترامي الأطراف في قلب المدينة،
أحد الأشياء التي أعشقها عندما أتيت إلى
كاليفورنيا هو بودنغ الأرز الذي
ستكون في المكان المناسب الذي
يحتوي على النوع المناسب من بودنغ الأرز
هل لديك
بودنغ الأرز
حسنًا، ما الذي حصلت عليه إنه
بودنغ الأرز مع المكسرات وبعض الفواكه والكريمة
في الأعلى، لقد كنت
أتطلع إلى هذا، فهم
دائمًا يصرخون بأن
البودنج المناسب ممتاز تمامًا،
لكنه لا يحصل  أفضل بكثير من
هذا، إنه ليس كذلك حقًا،
هذا كله
محصن بشكل ممتع، أنا الآن جاهز للمعركة، مرحبًا،
كيف حالك
الآن مع كل هذه الحلي الخشبية التي
تراها، هذا إذا كان بإمكاني العثور على طريقي
عبر الأرنب وارين  شوارع
السوق، أوه، أحب هذه، أنظر إلى هذه [
الموسيقى]
إنها مصنوعة يدويًا، وهي محلية في
أي مكان قريب بمجرد وصولك إلى المنزل،
وهي قطعة واحدة في غرفة المعيشة
أو غرفة النوم الخاصة بك، فهي تأخذ شكلًا مختلفًا تمامًا،
حسنًا، حذرًا، لقد  اشتريتها للتو
وانظر إلى الألوان والجميلة،
وأنا سعيد جدًا وأشعر أنني حصلت على
صفقة جيدة حقًا، شكرًا جزيلاً لك أيها
الأجنبي